[Music]  she works really hard for my money Katy  Perry is the queen of quick changes yep  that's the pop star with her new purple  do hanging from a bar above her head  while at least three people zip her up  and put on her hat and boots before she  heads back onstage in Paris France while  Perry was able to get all her clothes on  before returning to the stage this time  you can't control everything  she hasn't always been as lucky when it  comes to her wardrobe I don't need to  over expose myself in March the American  Idol judge was dancing with a contestant  on the show when she fell over and  exposed herself I'm the best dancer in  Georgia of course her fellow judges  Lionel Richie and Luke Bryan were there  to help but not without a little teasing  there are things a man can unsee and in  April she suffered another wardrobe  malfunction  when she split her seam  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]